My wife and I suffered
three weeks of turmoil,
which including losing,
which included losing a child.
How do I expedite that moment
when we pick up ourselves,
pick ourselves up and keep moving forward
because I am done sulking and we need
to move forward basically
how to push through.
So
yeah,
I mean obviously that's heartbreaking and
I can't even imagine the pain that you
are going through in this situation.
It's one of those things,
we've talked about this before.
The fact is we don't really
have a cultural protocol
for what to do when we lose
a loved one
and you have to basically
make up that protocol.
I can't,
I can't dictate what that
protocol is going to be for you,
but I can
tell you some things from my perspective,
from some of the things
that I've been through.
I can tell you my perspective on loss
and the first thing is that you
already know it's going to be wretched
and you're not going to escape it.
And that pain in this is,
this is something that I've identified.
The pain that's going to come,
it's going to come in waves and at first
you won't even notice that their waves
because all the waves are going to be so
close together and they're going to be
so continual and they're going to be right
on top of each other and the pain and
the sadness is going to
feel like it's so heavy.
It's going to feel like
you are drowning in sorrow.
Like you're not going to get any air
and like you're not going to be able to
escape that sadness.
That's what the waves feel like at first.
And then at some point there's
going to be a little break,
just a little break, just a little
bit of light in the darkness.
Something is going to make you smile,
something is going to make you laugh.
Something's gonna just show
you just a little bit of light.
But I don't know when
that's going to happen.
Yeah.
And then you're going to see that little,
that little smile, that little light.
And then the,
uh,
another wave of pain is going to back
again and it's going to be strong and you
won't have any control over it. You
won't be able to say, no, no, I'm, I'm,
I'm in the right now, or I'm
smiling right now. I'm not gonna,
I'm not gonna go back there. No,
you're not going to able to control it.
And that's scary.
It's scary because we,
we get used to as adults,
hey,
we can kind of get control of things and
now all of a sudden you're not going to
have control. It's going to hit
you and you're going to feel it.
Okay?
But again,
like a wave,
like a wave in the ocean that is going
to eventually subside again and you'll
see a little bit of light and you'll get
a little bit of a smile and you'll feel
okay for a second. And then guess
what? Another wave's gonna hit you.
It might not be as strong
as that other way. D Wave.
And you might not even notice that
it's not as strong. But again,
you can't control your emotions
and you'll find yourself,
this is what I'm talking about factually.
You're going to be sitting there and
all of a sudden you're going to be just
crying uncontrollably.
That wave is going to hit you.
You're going to go from normal to just
crying uncontrollably and being sad.
That's what's going to happen. And it
again, in your mind, you can be thinking,
I can't control this as
it's a wave and you're,
you're at the mercy of
this ocean of sorrow,
but don't let that scare you.
Don't let that scare you cause I'm
telling you that that wave is going to
subside again and this is going to go on.
It's going to go on and the waves,
they will become weaker.
Okay?
And what you need to realize is just
because the waves are becoming weaker,
this doesn't mean that you love your
child less or you miss them less or that
you aren't crushed at their passing.
It just means that you're starting
to be able to deal with it,
which is what you're supposed to do.
And as the waves get weaker,
which they will,
they'll also appear less frequently.
And again,
that's okay.
It doesn't mean that you don't
think your child all the time,
it just means that it's being dealt with.
And while this is happening,
while you were, when you came,
when you start to, when the,
when the storm waves start
to come a little bit.
Okay.
What you can do is you can row the boat.
Yeah.
Kuro the boat.
Well,
and what I mean by that is start doing
something productive to get your mind
moving forward. I don't know
how long this is, this, this is,
you know,
when you feel a little bit of a break,
then let's do it.
A few days go by,
five days go by,
three days go by.
At some point you can't cry anymore.
Okay,
let's do something productive.
Let's sort out the drawers in the bedroom.
Let's back you.
Let's finish a product.
Let's do something productive.
And if there's something
that distracts you, that's fine. Do it.
Let, let, let there be
some calm in the water
and also as the, as the calm coms.
Yeah.
Also you're going to find
moments where it's like you can,
you can have things that are
going to bring on the waves
and that's okay to bring on the waves.
Go look at the pictures right
down the memories. Read the
letters, read the notes,
read the emails,
remember?
All right.
And then there's that standard service.
You're going to do the memorial,
you're going to do the burial.
And when that's over,
let a little bit of more time go by.
Give yourself another week.
Yeah,
of washing around
a feeling that sorrow
of letting the waves,
okay,
toss you around in the ocean.
But after another week, what you do
is you go and you write a letter,
you write a letter to your child.
Hey, can you explain to them,
explain to them how
much they meant to you.
Explain to them how heartbroken
you are that they are gone.
And then explain to them why
you are going to carry on.
Why you are going to keep going
with them in your heart.
Explain to them why you're not
going to dwell in their loss
and explain to them how in losing them
you have learned without a shred of
doubt,
how truly precious life is,
and that they have taught you
the immeasurable value of your own life
and your wife's life and your family's
life.
And explain to them that you know
that you know that they loved you and
that you know that they would want more
than anything for you to be happy and
productive and impactful in the world.
And explained in that letter what you
will do to make them proud of how you live
your life.
And then take that letter
and go to their grave
and read it to them
and cry
and kiss their soul
and tell them that you'll
see them on the other side
and then
go live your life.
And those waves are still gonna come
and they're still going to be pain
and they're still going to be sorrow.
But you go and live your
life and live it well
and make them proud.